les agriculteurs quant à eux veulent
aussi pesé sur cette campagne des
régionales un enjeu de taille puisque le
centre val de loire est la première
région productrice de céréales il
propose donc aux candidats de signer un
pacte objectif les inciter à s'engager
en faveur de la profession de la gestion
de l'eau à la sensibilisation des jeunes
c'est notre carnet de campagne ce soir
un reportage de florent clavel réalisé
aujourd'hui à saint-ouen dans le
loir-et-cher l'agriculture en centre val
de loire c'est 35 mille emplois directs
et des fleurons vins fromages fruits et
céréales un secteur qui pèse mais
constamment crise ces dernières années
cette élection régionale
c'est l'opportunité d'un dialogue direct
avec des élus en campagne comme ce matin
dans cette ferme loir et chérienne ils
sont là pour nous écouter après on verra
quoi voilà c'est ça mais ce but il est
là quand même c'est de nous écouter à la
clé la signature d'un pacte agricole et
l'engagement de soutenir la filière
l'objectif de se pacser d'expliquer une
autre vision de l'agriculture qu'on a
pour ces prochaines années
c'est bien joli d'être passionné d'être
accompagné il faut arriver à redonner de
la performance économique à
l'agriculture j'achète mon songe à soi
disant non ogm qui vient du brésil ou
dans tout aujourd'hui sa production de
leur sens de la barre que le première
chez moi alors je le produit localement
quoi on est prêt à regarder territoire
par territoire
sur cette liste engagé quatre ont envoyé
leurs représentants ps lr et rennes et
modem
l'équipe élue aura la gestion du fonds
européen agricole
une enveloppe de 345 millions d'euros
sur six ans mais attention la signature
de ce pacte
c'est un signal envoyé aux paysans pas
un chèque en blanc insiste ce candidat
il ya des sujets clivants 6-1 sur la
méthanisation sur l'eau sur les
éoliennes
et parfois la responsabilité de l'élu
c'est aussi de dire qu'on peut pas faire
tout n'importe où et qu' il ya des
contraintes et que ce sont des sujets
extrêmement complexe sur lequel il faut
savoir raison garder l'agriculture est
un tournant et les candidats aux
régionales l'ont bien compris dans les
dix prochaines années en centre val de
loire dix mille chefs d'exploitation
devront être remplacés alors que dans le
même temps les vocations ne cesse de
baisser